warum ich dieses video auch machen nicht
nur weil ich persönlich das erzählen
möchte unbedingt sondern auch weil ich
denke dass es vielleicht für leute die
auch gerade ich so was gehen in beispiel
sein kann und herzlich willkommen zu
einem neuen video wir werden heute ein
bisschen ernst das thema ansprechen das
heißt alle die auf ein bisschen ernstes
thema keinen bock haben ihr könnt ruhig
wegschalten ich werde heute mal eine
geschichte aus meinem leben erzählen die
sehr prägend für mich war und die
sicherlich ein paar leute von euch
interessiert das schon mal als
disclaimer vorher ich möchte ich heute
echt mal eine geschichte aus meinem
leben erzählt über eine ziemlich schwere
phase weil ich finde ganz ehrlich in
letzter zeit
ich merke das auch selbst so ziemlich
viel klick bate scheiße auf meinem kanal
und so ich meine das ist mal auch mal
ganz witzig aber mir war es wichtig mal
wieder ein bisschen persönlich inhalte
zu bringen war wirklich wieder mehr mit
euch zu kommunizieren gut viele youtube
würden jetzt sagen so öh
warum soll ich denn irgendwas wenn mein
privatleben auf youtube erzählen das
geht die leute ja doch nichts an
es gibt viele die so denken ich
persönlich denke nicht so dankeschön
facebook das facebook-konto die chance
erhalten bitte facebook besser gehabt er
mit um euch den scheiß aus es gibt viele
die so denken so geht meine zwischen
oder nichts an was ich in meinem
privatleben mache mir persönlich geht es
nicht so ich finde nämlich als ihr müsst
euch das mal vorstellen leute ich setze
mich idealerweise jeden tag hin ich
schaff's nicht jeden tag video
hochzuladen aber sechs tage die woche
setze ich mich hin und nehmen wir für
euch auf und steigt dann zwei bis drei
stunden lang jeden einzelnen tag youtube
ist so ein wichtiger bestandteil in
meinem leben wie kann ich dann sagen
meine zuschauer geht man mein
privatleben überhaupt nichts an
youtube ist mein privatleben youtube ist
immer privaten übergegangen und youtube
reeckmann leben deswegen finde ich es
nur passend dass man den leuten für die
man sich jeden tag hin setzt 34 stunden
lang dass man den leuten auch ein
bisschen was erzählt dass es mein
persönliches bedürfnis müssen natürlich
nicht auszumachen
aber ich mag das gerne so und deswegen
let's roll hat mich in letzter zeit viel
mit dem thema beschäftigt dass ich heute
ansprechen möchte viel über meine meine
vergangenheit nachgedacht und ich denke
dass da kann ich vielleicht ein ganz
gutes beispiel sein also leute haltet
euch fest
schneider jan es geht los auf den trip
down the fierce lane fangen wir an im
jahr 2000
6 ich glaub ende des jahres 2006 da
haben wir noch in hessen gewohnt haben
sich meine eltern getrennt und das hat
dazu geführt dass mein vater in hessen
blieb und wir umgezogen sind nach bayern
alles klar heißt neue schule neue
schulsystem und jeder das schon mal
gemacht hat von hessen nach bayern
umziehen und vom hessischen schulsystem
ins bayerische schulsystem zu wechseln
der weiß das ist ein absoluter
selbstmord ist also hessen ist easy
peasy im vergleich zu bayern bayern ist
deutlich schwieriger das kann ich selbst
bezeugen also war generell so ein
bisschen eklige phase eltern getrennt
und so merkt ganz ganz blöden zeit wenn
man selbst sich gerade noch irgendwo das
heißt ich finde wohl die pubertät gerade
los geht und alles drunter und drüber
geht wenn sich in dieser zeit die eltern
trennen ist auf jeden fall nicht sogar
gut dazu kamera dann dass wir neue
schule gegangen bin
in bayern deutlich schwieriger deutlich
schwieriger ohren ich sowieso immer zwei
drei jahre jünger war als alle anderen
das ist es jetzt eigentlich wirklich
meine lebensgeschichte in diesem video
krass alter okay ich war 23 jahre jünger
weil ich erstens früher eingeschult
wurde
das heißt mit fünf statt sechs jahren
und dazu auch noch die man ich bin eine
geschichte erzählen könnte auch wenn zu
bimmeln überall hohen blieb manamana
wurde mit fünf eingeschult und hab dann
die vierte klasse übersprungen und
dadurch immer zwei jahre jünger und das
hat sich nach dem schulwechsel nach
bayern ziemlich krass gezeigt also in
hessen hatte ich nie probleme immer
super verstand mit den klassenkameraden
aber in bayern hatte ich dann auf einmal
null kontakt mehr zu meinen
klassenkameraden wir haben uns überhaupt
nicht überschnitten so von unseren
interessen
das hat sich dann ziemlich krass gezeigt
zwar wurde ich halt einfach überhaupt 0
in diese klasse integriert so integriert
so damals ich war damals habe ich zehn
oder elf und die leute aus der klasse in
bayern inhalt zwölf oder dreizehn soja
das hat dazu geführt dass die haltung
der pubertät waren die eine ahnung haben
sich damals für für mädels interessiert
haben irgendwie angefangen zu denken das
es besonders wichtig ist irgendwelche
coolen klamotten zu tragen und so mich
hat das hat damals nicht gejuckt und
dafür wurde ich ziemlich krass fertig
gemacht und das ist der point an der
ganzen geschichte
darum geht's in der achten klasse
habe ich dann ja ganz ehrlich einfach
nur freunde 0 0,0 und bin opfer ziemlich
heftigen mobbing geworden das war oft
verbal also wörtlich war auch körperlich
also auch körperliche gewalt oder dass
zb die erste deiner sport und kleide
verschwindet irgendwo schuhe oder so du
weißt ganz genau dass es kein zufall ist
weil ich gefühl die ganze klasse hat
aber du kannst nichts machen weil die
person weil er nicht weiß wer es war so
eine scheiße
dazu kommt dass niemand in der klasse
mit ihr reden will dass du in der klasse
keine freunde hast total isoliert bist
und deine eltern sich gerade getrennt
haben und ihre probleme hat in der
schule du irgendwie kurz davor wissen
sitzen zu bleiben was eigentlich
überhaupt nicht zu dir passt würde
eigentlich hin weil weil ich eigentlich
ein relativ schmal das kind weil dieser
klasse übersprungen für einen schub nie
probleme gehabt in der schule aber dann
in bayern nachdem man eltern sich
getrennt hatten
nachdem ich die schule gewechselt habe
und in der klasse schwierigkeiten hat
nicht nur schwierigkeiten hatten eine
total ausgegrenzt war und von denen noch
gemobbt wurde
das war nicht so mit der der tiefste
punkt in meinem leben glaube ich bisher
da war es echt so ich war froh wenn ich
nicht in die schule gehen musste wenn
die verändert haben bin ich ja ziemlich
ausgerastet und hat meiner mutter
gebeten nicht in die schule gehen zu
müssen weil ich da ihn fertig gemacht
wurde und das schlimme ist ja auch die
lehrer zeigen in so einem fall keine
sympathien ist oder der griffigkeit zu
aggressiv nicht so die fresse schlagen
sowie für die klare wortwahl aber wisst
ihr mann ist schon so in die ecke
gedrängt mann ist sozial so ausgegrenzt
in der klasse
und dann hatten die lehrer auch noch auf
einem rum weil man schlechte noten hat
wie soll man sich denn auf die schule
konzentrieren
wie soll man dann irgendwann in seinem
leben gebacken kriegen wenn alles den
bach runtergeht es geht gar nicht aber
ja ok anschauen eines unterstützen
hacken lehrer dann zusätzlich auf amrum
ist auch nicht so leicht für die aber
ganz ehrlich das macht mir einfach nur
sauer so die achte klasse war echt die
absolute hölle da habe ich ja weg sich
die schule jetzt keine ahnung gehen hier
zur schule ich habe letztens mit einem
freund darüber geredet und der meinte ja
wir hassen das durchgestanden
keine ahnung ich weiß es nicht
irgendwie hat es geklappt irgendwas
geklappt wie habe ich nicht aufgegeben
die neue klasse war dann auch ziemlich
heftig zehnte ging so elf personen und
ab der 12 weil es so halbwegs erträglich
ist zwar noch nicht wirklich lebenswert
aber es war zumindest halbwegs
erträglich du hast trägt leute einfach
richtig krass solche erlebnisse und
also in jederlei hinsicht ich habe heute
noch misstrauen gegenüber menschen
prinzipiell als ich misstraue menschen
erstmal weil man einfach so oft ja
verletzt verarscht wurde wie man es
nennen mag misstraut man den leuten weiß
also man man denkt sich nicht ohne neuer
mensch der ist bestimmt lieb und nett
und den mag ich auch wenn ich noch nicht
fix ersten moment will der mich jetzt
wieder verarschen will er mich verletzen
und hat er blinkt was das für nur an
sohn und dem los man hat damit es ist
schon eine sache an der man bisschen
trägt aber warum ich dieses video auch
mache nicht nur weil ich persönlich das
erzählen möchte unbedingt sondern auch
weil ich denke dass es vielleicht für
leute die auch gerade ich so was gehen
in beispiel sein kann dass es nicht
immer so scheiße bleibt das ist echt
nicht immer so scheiße bleibt wenn ich
heute mit leuten rede und wollte mit
leuten erzähle was damals passiert ist
bei mir denn diese so hell wie wie das
das sieht man ja gar nicht an soll das
hätte ich jetzt überhaupt nicht gedacht
und das ist einfach ein zeichen dafür
dass man die zeit wirklich durchstehen
kann
und da echt dinge verändern kann alles
ist es wirklich möglich und jeder der
draußen der jetzt in einer ähnlichen
situation ist und auch gerade irgendwie
scheiße frist aus irgendeinem grund
zähne zusammenbeißen zähne zusammen
beißen sie irgendwie zu wir die lage so
angenehm wie möglich machen könnt und
wenn es nicht anders geht dann einfach
auf die welt und vertraut euch selbst
und zieht die sache durch wenn es
irgendwie können zieht die sache durch
am ende des tunnels ist auf jeden fall
nicht kann ich jetzt bestätigen ich muss
wirklich sagen mein leben erholt sich
jetzt so langsam weiß nicht ob man sie
jetzt denken so first world problems
oder du bist dich in fucking in syrien
aufgewachsen keine ahnung aber das ist
echt schon übel also das macht einen
echt schon ziemlich fertig und das prägt
auch fürs ganze leben wie gesagt ich
habe heute teilweise noch soja
misstrauen gegenüber menschen das macht
nicht so easy irgendwie neue leute
kennenzulernen oder so oder leute an
sich heranzulassen keeper pipapo aber
wie gesagt ich würde einfach ein zeichen
an alle leute da draußen geben die
vielleicht auch irgendwie scheiße
durchstehen müssen wegen
klassenkameraden die sie irgendwie
fertig machen weil sie nicht die coolen
klamotten haben oder keine ahnung also
es ist
wird besser leute wirklich ihr könnt
jeden fall durchstehen es ist immer noch
ein bisschen komisches gefühl dass jetzt
einfach zu schneiden und hochzuladen auf
youtube aber ich glaube das ist schon
schon das richtige glaube ich hier
kannst du stirbst du auch mal so so habe
ich die fackel grunde schon gewonnen ich
bin jetzt immer noch nicht auf dem
niveau wo ich sagen wo ich sage so okay
mein leben ist so wie es sein sollte
aber seit der schulzeit setzte
verdammten achten klasse habe ich so
krasses fortschritte gemacht und ihr
draußen können dass auf jeden fall auch
schafft ihr ja sehr motivation die leute
die sowas nicht durchgestanden haben
denke ich jetzt wahrscheinlich so hübsch
ist oder so aber ich glaube das kann
wirklich ein paar leuten da draußen
helfen wenn ihr euch traut werde ich
unter diesem video ganz besonders in die
kommentare schon ihr könnt ihr eure
geschichten erzählen aber vielleicht
etwas ähnliches erlebt habt wie ihr wie
ich euch seitdem gegangen ist aber
vielleicht jetzt gerade drin steckt das
ist glaube ich eine ganz gute sache ja
endlich mal die reichweite sinnvoll
eingesetzt hatte das war's das war meine
geschichte man macht sich damit krass
verletzbar finde ich zumindest also ich
hab jetzt mega viel aus meinem leben
erzählt das wissen paar kumpels von mir
aber nicht was jetzt gerade erzählt habe
wir hoffen einfach mal dass es gut
aufgenommen wird von euch so das war so
bis zum eine geschichte jetzt ist es da
draußen und eure stories dazu in die
kommentare eure meinung ich hoffe ich
habe es jetzt so erzählt wie es erzählen
wollte das war zu viel für ihre haut
rein macht's gut
und 2